So how can we tell if a game
is actually engaging?
Well, we can usually look
at how popular the game is
by finding out if the game is downloaded
a lot and if the reviews are good.
For example, here we can see
game apps in Amazon Appstore.
And we can see the number of reviews and
the star rating from one to five stars.
And this gives us a good idea
of how engaging our game is.
If the game has a rating close to
five stars, it's probably pretty fun.
And if it's lower, then maybe there's
something the users don't like about it.
We can also look at how long and
how often players use our game, and
measure engagement.
Here are some terms we
used to measure it.
Session count, session length,
and retention.
Session count is the number
of times an app is launched.
So any time a player opens the app,
whether that's once a week or
ten times a day,
the session count goes up.
And if we look at the average session
counts for a player over a day.
We can get a pretty good idea
of how addicting our game is.
But some games are designed for
longer sessions instead of multiple
short sessions, so
the session length is also important.
Session length is the amount of
time that the app is in use for
a particular session.
So whether that's a few minutes or
going on and on to a length of hours.
And again for this to be a useful metric
we would usually look at the average,
the average person length across users
to see how long a typical user plays
once they open the app.
And we also look at retention.
Which is a measure of how many
users continue to play your game
as time goes on.
Usually game retention is measured a day
after your game is first launched and
downloaded, a week after, and
the month after just to see
how many of your original
players you keep over time.
Say you want to measure retention
over week for the game Fruit Ninja.
That means you want to see how many
people who start at the beginning
of the week are still around
at the end of the week.
During the week some of these early
users will leave Fruit Ninja.
And new ones will join.
But we don't want to take
into account the new ones.
We just want to see who started
at the beginning of the week and
stayed throughout the whole week.
To calculate this, you need to look
at the users at the end of the week
minus any of the newcomers who
joined in the middle of the week,
all divided by the number of users that
started at the beginning of the week.
Then multiply all this by
100 to get a percentage and
this is going to be your retention for
the week.
So let's look at some numbers for
Fruit Ninja.
Let's say we had 400 people download
the game at the start of the week and
there's 700 total by
the end of the week.
That looks pretty good.
But we also know that 500
of these people are new.
They joined in the middle
of the week and
they are part of our 400
original starting players.
So let's calculate the retention.
First we have 700 from
the end of the week,
minus the 500 new players
that joined mid-week.
So we are only accounting for our
original 400 to see who stuck around.
All divided by our 400 original players.
Then times 100 to get a percentage.
This is going to be 200 over 400 or
half times 100%
which is going to give us 50% retention
over this week, which is pretty good.
Ideally we'd want 100% retention,
which means everyone who downloads your
game keeps playing it and never quits.
But no game has perfect retention and
even really great games have around 50%
retention after just the first day.
That means that half the players leave
during the first 24 hours of playing.
This seems like a lot of people leaving,
but it's considered pretty good or
a tension especially for a game that as
good at getting new players over time.
It won't matter that a lot
of older ones leave.
Lots of developers use a 40,
20, ten rule as a guideline for
good retention over a day a week and
a month.
So after a game is downloaded by a bunch
of people we have 100% of people.
Forty percent of those users
stick around after the first day.
Twenty percent of those stay for
a week and only ten percent stay for
a whole month and even longer usually.
If you have retention at these
time points a day, a week or
a month that's higher that's great.
If it's any lower that's
considered bad retention